Okay, as everyone's getting seated, I think we'll get started.
I'm Ben Cravatt. I'm a professor just up the road here at Scripps Research in the
Department of Chemistry.
Had the great opportunity to organize this session on molecular
glues and heterobifunctional small molecules
for biological discovery and therapeutic development.
So I don't think that topic needs much introduction in this audience, but what
I really look for is young investigators, and Nathaniel.
Just kidding.
As leaders in this field,
who are really pushing the frontiers of not only glues as
protein degradation mechanisms, but as I think Nathaniel will talk about, glues for
gain-of-function outcomes. And I think
as Nathaniel will highlight, we're just at the tip of the iceberg in how these
sorts of small molecule-induced protein biomolecular
association mechanisms can impact cell biology and by
extension, cancer biology. And so, I think we have a great session
in store for you. We're going to take questions after each talk.
My job now is just to be
ringmaster of ensuring we stay on time.
And beyond that, you're not here to hear me.
So
our first speaker is, I'd like to introduce is Nathaniel Gray, who this audience
needs no introduction. At Stanford University, he's been an incredible leader,
not just in the field of molecular glue discovery and bifunctional discovery, but
also in developing cancer therapeutics, novel
cancer mechanisms, allosteric mechanisms for regulating kinases.
Not only a colleague, but a close friend.
So Nathaniel,
come to the stage, and look forward to hearing your work.
Thanks so much for that kind introduction.
Yeah, I think you know you've hit middle age when you've got the kids of your
former trainees working in your lab.
So that's always exciting. So I thought what we'd talk about
today is molecular glues to induce cancer cell
death.
So these are my disclosures. Most relevant today is Shenandoah that's licensed some
of the gain-of-function molecules. So I have sort of three parts.
First, I want to convince you of the magic of chemically induced proximity,
especially as it relates to gain-of-function.
And then I'm going to talk about using it to modulate the activity of two really
critical transcription factors, BCL6 and p53.
So as a field in oncology, we've been heavily
focused on inhibition. So finding so-called
cancer dependencies, and then inhibiting them.
So mutant EGFR, mutant ALK, half of this
meeting is about mutant RAS inhibitors.
And of course, when you do that, you put the cells under extreme
selective pressure to try to incur mutations or bypass
signaling pathways. So we began to think, is there a fundamentally different
way to target cancer through rewiring?
Okay. So here the idea is we're not going to inhibit
the oncogenic driver. We're going to redirect it to lead to a
new function. Okay, so you've seen these kind of
bivalent molecules most frequently in PROTACs for degradation,
where you are degrading the target.
But here what we're doing is we're trying to create a new signal that
instead of leading to loss of function, actually leads to a gain of
function.
So the first place we started applying this was, could we
create gain of function by creating a conduit
between cancer drivers and the apoptotic pathway?
So we know cells,
when our bodies want to eliminate cells naturally, they don't
inhibit the essential function of one protein, right?
They induce the apoptotic cascade, and apoptosis,
through
programmed cell death, goes after many essential genes because you
can't leave death to chance of just inhibiting one
protein. So if you really want to eliminate cancer cells, you need to induce
a more comprehensive program. So the idea here is can you create a
sort of a short circuit between a cancer driver
directly into the cell death pathway?
So what are the steps for chemically induced proximity?
So first, you have to have a target that you're going to go after.
So in the case that we've been working on is transcription factors, but this could
be any oncogenically associated protein.
Then you have this recruitment step.
And again, most people are familiar with PROTACs where the effector is an E3
ligase. But now the effector can be something that will lead to a
gain-of-function signal. And then finally, you get this
activation. And the examples I'll go through today are transcriptional
rewiring. But you can imagine many other cellular fates, and you've people have
probably heard about ones in this meeting involving
multimerization, relocalization, induced
phosphorylation, enhanced DNA damage.
And the idea is substoichiometrically to lead to cell
death through this new pathway.
So one other really important point that I think gets confused is
what's the fundamental difference between gain of function and
loss of function? So all three modalities shown on the left,
conventional inhibition, RIP-TAG, or degradation, are
fundamentally loss-of-function approaches.
So the idea is to fully eliminate a target in order to get
the consequences of that elimination.
And typically, the pharmacological effect requires complete
elimination of that target, which either requires catalytic
activity on the side of the ligase for degradation, or if it's an
occupancy-based approach,
like the classical rapamycin, cyclosporine type
interaction where you fully sequester a protein with FKBP or cyclosporine,
or with calcineurin, that's a full sequestration.
So this is fundamentally different from a gain-of-pharmacology approach,
right? So you're creating a neomorphic interaction in cells
that leads to a fundamentally different outcome.
And most outcomes we've looked at so far have been cell death, but you can
imagine many other outcomes. And one of the
fundamentally distinguishing qualities is this happens at a fractional
occupancy. So you don't need a molecular glue that achieves
stoichiometric binding of the target.
You might only be hijacking 10% of the protein.
And that means that you can get away
withinteractions and small molecules that have much
lower affinity because you're fundamentally achieving less receptor
occupancy but still getting the cellular effect.
So loss of function versus gain of function.
So the first system that we've been
characterizing has been BCL6. And here the idea
was, BCL6 is known to be a death regulator and gets
upregulated in lymphoma as a way of preventing cell
death. So the idea we had together with Jerry Crabtree's lab was could
you make a molecular glue that would convert BCL6 from being
a transcriptional repressor to being a activator?
So the idea is normally BCL6 epigenetically
represses transcription by binding on
chromatin, and it does so in complex with a whole series of
corepressors. So chemists at Boehringer Ingelheim had built some very
beautiful compounds that targeted the BTB domain.
And so their idea at the time had been to de-repress by
dissociating these corepressors, B-COR, N-COR, and
SMART. So those compounds have some activity but don't lead to
robust
induction of apoptosis. So our idea was instead of just
displacing those corepressors, now let's turbocharge the
protein by recruiting in BRD4. So essentially we're
creating now a synthetic transcription factor
where you have a sort of Frankenstein interaction now between
BRD4 and BCL6,
and that then induces the expression of BCL6-dependent gene
expression program.
So what do these molecules look like in practice?
So they kind of look like PROTAC-type molecules.
So these are heterobifunctional molecules where on one side we
have the BRD4 binder JQ1, and then this BTB domain
binder. And whenever we do this chemistry, we make negative controls where we
either disable binding on the left side or the right side by subtle mutations.
And then we have a reporter gene assay, and this is fundamentally where you can see
that it's a gain-of-function mechanism.
So here, as we induce gluing between BRD4 and
BCL6, we turn on a BCL6-dependent
reporter with an EC50 of about five nanomolar.
And classical of these molecular glues, it shows a hook-like
behavior. So at a critical concentration, you stimulate ternary complex
formation; too high or too low, and you don't get that effect.
So what does this molecule do across chromatin?
So if you do ChIP-seq for BRD4, you'll basically see
that the molecule relocalizes BRD4 to
BCL6 loci. And the consequence of that
relocalization is to induce BCL6-dependent
gene expression. So here are some of the key apoptotic proteins like
NOXA, and you look at
ChIP for RNA Pol II, you can see as a function of time, you
rapidly induce RNA Pol II at the NOXA
locus. And the reason this molecule is so wickedly potent
is you're not simply inducing one gene, it's the entire
BCL6 transcriptional program that gets activated.
And it's actually a much more pronounced activation
than you see if you just eliminate BCL6.
So it's eliminating BCL6, then you no longer are
repressing those genes, but now instead you're hyperactivating this
expression. And so if you look at any measure of protein abundance
in transcriptional changes, cell death, you get a much more pronounced
effect with these kind of bivalent molecules.
We've been able to show that these molecules work in vivo in collaboration with
Michael Green's lab at MD Anderson.
So these are lymphoma models that are heavily pretreated with
previous chemotherapy. And what you can see is that you only see
activity in models where BCL6 is high.
So here we get nice control of tumor growth at quite modest
doses. However, if you have a tumor model where it's BCL6 low
or BCL6 negative, the cells grow right through this
molecule. So again, this is a molecule that relies on
hyperactivation of BCL6 to exert the activity and
the induction of apoptosis.
The other neat thing about these transcriptional inducers of proximity
is it's not just one effector you can bring there.
So we've actually now been able to extend this to two other effectors,
CDK9, using this
compound initially made by Bristol Myers Squibb,
or a bromodomain binder of p300 to making a
p300 BCL6 TIP. All of these can induce
BCL6-dependent gene expression, but they do so in different ways,
and you get different sets of genes that are activated.
So with TIPs, unlike with the degrader, where fundamentally you're seeing loss of
function, here you can get a different flavor of induction
depending on the effector that you bring there.
And these are now both published stories, so if you want to see the details, I
refer you to those papers.
So is this unique to
BCL6? So another protein we started looking at was
p53. So this has been well-recognized as
the most universally dysregulated tumor suppressor.
And there's been beautiful effort from a number of companies to make essentially
corrector molecules. And so one of the mutants that's been attempted to be
corrected is this Y220C, both with covalent and
non-covalent molecules. Last year, there was a beautiful
publication showing this rosettaphot can stabilize
p53 and induce cell death. There was lots of preclinical work.
And then beautiful clinical trial data published in "New
England Journal of Medicine" showing sort of the first pharmacological
evidence that you can reactivate a tumor suppressor.
Obviously, you can't do that if the tumor suppressor is completely lost.
But in this case, it's just a mutation.
So we wanted to ask, can you further enhance this
through a induced proximity interaction?So we did this
again, recruiting BRD4. So we build a
library of molecules, and then we screen them for their ability to induce
ternary complex formation and induce gene expression,
do a lot of chemistry similar to what you would do with PROTACs, understanding the
optimal geometry of the linkers.
And we found a compound here we call TRAP-1 for a
activation molecule. So it's a p53, Y220C,
BRD4 induced proximity molecule.
You get nice induction of protein-protein interaction, and then
that's associated with turning on p53 dependent
expression. So in this case, the molecules are not as potent as we
saw for BCL6, but conceivably with more medicinal
chemistry, they can be further optimized.
But you can really see robust activation of p53 dependent
genes. So for example, p21, MDM2, very
strongly activated by these molecules leading to enhanced
cellular effects. So again, this is not a pure
p53 stabilization. You're now creating a chimera
between this p53 stabilizer and BRD4.
But many times you actually don't have a binder to the factor
that you want to look at. And so one factor we wanted to look at is
EWS-FLI. This is a driver oncogene in Ewing
sarcoma that we've collaborated with Kim Stegmaier's lab,
and we basically made a fusion protein with
FKBP, and then we made, similar to the dTag
system for degradation, this sort of a dTag system for
transcriptional activation. We could then build a bivalent between the
dTag and again, the BCL6 binder. So BCL6
is not the most relevant transcription factor
in Ewing sarcoma, but it still regulates gene expression, and
through an analysis, we figured out that one of the genes regulated by
BCL6 is SOX2.
And we could show that this heterobivalent can recruit
EWS-FLI to BCL6 loci and induce expression
of this gene. So this is a really neat way that if you don't
necessarily know whether you have a ligand and what will be the
transcriptional consequences of the induced proximity, you can basically make
this as a designer system to see what will happen to validate
the effector.
So just in summary,
I think we've seen great progress now in the field of induced
proximity with degradation or with classical
sort of RIP-tag type blocking interactions.
But this gain-of-function that you can see at low occupancy with transcription
factors really, I think, is going to enable a lot of new targets.
And partly the reason this is such a powerful approach is
that the degree of gluing that you need may only be
fractional. So you may not need a nanomolar
scale ligand at either side. So, for example, you might have
primarily ligand binding to BRD4, and then you might have
basically a small functionality to induce interaction with
your target of interest. And because it happens at this substoichiometric binding,
that may be enough to see the pharmacological effect.
So I hope as a field,
we can be convinced that gain-of-function can be superior
to loss-of-function. But of course, there's lots of open questions related to
gain-of-function about what other effects you're going to see
at low occupancy for inducing gene expression.
But I think there's many targets to be explored, and you can
actually get gain-of-function on targets that
are already credentialed, where you're basically trying to turn that
target into a death signal for cells.
So let me stop there and thank some really amazing people.
All this was highly collaborative science, together with Gerry
Crabtree on the TSIPs. This is our TSIP
transcriptional team that led the initial work.
Lots of more stories that are coming.
Shijun Wang-Sub led the p53 effort and then
the EWS-FLI dTagging effort together with Michael Bond and
Kim Stegmaier's lab. So I'll stop there, and thank you for your
attention.
You can say hi to-- All right.
Okay, so I think the way this works is obviously we'll take questions from the
audience, and then if you're online, I think you can QR code
and send questions here, and I'll figure out how to balance it. So go ahead.
Yeah. Hi, very nice talk. I'm Kevin Coleman from GSK.
We heard about the RIP Tags, the AR, BRD4
AR, p300. How do you know when you
start if you're going to develop an inhibitory RIP-tag or it could be a
TSIP?
Is there rules?
Yeah. So I think it's, are you expecting the signal to come
from gain-of-function or
loss-of-function?
So
with the induced gluing interaction, there's sort of multiple advantages that you
can see. So you might get cell specificity
from one side of the equation, one of the partner proteins.
That's part of it. Then the other part is, are you seeing a
signal because one protein is causing loss-of-function of the other
protein, or is it fundamentally a neomorphic interaction,
which is gain-of-function? And then finally, if it is a
cooperative gluing interaction, then there can be an advantageous
disposition of the pharmacology in that glued complex.
All three of those things can widen your therapeutic
index for affecting the cell type that you want to see.
So in some degrees, it's semantics, and I think we should be a little bit
careful as a field
ascribing where the functional effect is coming
from, because, yeah, it can be sequestration, it can be relocalization,
transcriptional activation. So until you've done those downstream analyses, it's
hard to know necessarily where the pharmacology is coming from.
And that, I think, also relates to this issue ofWhen you see the
pharmacology,
is your model translationally
relevant, right? And we've all been down the road of killing cells very
effectively in culture, and then it doesn't translate.
So, is the gain-of-function signal that you're
seeing actually relevant?
But I assume it might have been possible that
the AR anchors BRD4 from its normal function, so you're inhibiting
BRD4. But bringing BRD4
to AR locus, you might be rewiring
the AR locus?
Yes. So, yeah.
I haven't seen a
detailed publication on that compound, but my guess is you're getting
deranged transcription from AR,
and that's part of it as well. So that's the trick with these compounds, right?
There's effects in the binary complex, potentially from
inhibition, and then there's effects in the ternary complex.
So you're already seeing compound pharmacology from those
different sites, and you have to tease out where the different components come
from.
Mm-hmm. Okay, we have a couple questions online too that I think are really good.
So one of them is we
talked about this before, actually.
Why does the recruitment of BRD4 or CDK9 through an
inhibitory ligand to BCL6
activate transcription of BCL6 bound genes?
Yeah, so that's a great question. So
yeah, with CDK9, we're actually recruiting with a ATP
competitive CDK9 inhibitor, but the net effect we see of
that recruitment is induction of RNA Pol II
phosphorylation. So in that case, it really seems to be that we're getting
a catch and release mechanism. So we recruit
with the ligand, but then it gets released and phosphorylates RNA
polymerase II and induces transcription.
And the best evidence we have of that is when we went to highly potent
CDK9 binders, it stopped working as a TSIP.
Mm-hmm.
So we really needed
just the right
affinity of ligand to achieve the effect.
And that's, again, I think, where you have to figure out is it
a gain-of-function effect where you need dissociation
or do you need to lock down the most stable ternary complex?
And that's where the pharmacology comes from.
Yeah. Okay.
You mentioned the hook effect. How does it affect the therapeutic window
or the pharmacokinetic points later on in the clinical
scenarios?
Yeah. No, so that's a great question as well.
So I think it really depends on
the gain-of-function signal. Does it start a
irreversible reaction in the cell?
So in the case of BCL6, it turns on the proapoptotic program
really quickly, and we've shown with, we call them the kiss of death
experiments, transient exposure of the cells will send
the signal in that direction. But if the gain-of-function requires
continual exposure for a long time, then perhaps
the hook effect can be deleterious.
Of course, when you have a compound with normal
PK parameters, it often traverses the critical
concentration range. And then just like we've seen with PROTACs, you can
design it so the plateau of where you're seeing the
ternary complex is sufficiently broad.
Another question online relates to, in the p53 system, some of
those proteins that are variants that are overexpressed may not be functional.
And so how might a gain-of-function type approach be useful when the
mutant protein is dysmorphic, even though it's overexpressed?
Yeah, no, I think that's
really interesting. So I think, different mutant forms and different
proteoforms possibly can lead to different neomorphic
activities. Right? If you think about it, this approach of induced proximity is
how evolution works. Evolution works through a
mutation on a protein surface leading to a new interaction,
leading to a new signaling paradigm.
So in a sense, this is a chemically induced
biomimetic approach of
rewiring. And I think one of the things we're going to have to learn over time is,
how does homeostasis reestablish after this rewiring
effect? There will be some cases probably where it's reversible or it's
less reversible, and I think we're going to have to learn about that over time.
I think one of the big challenges in the field is
finding the right effectors and predicting where you're going
to see the gain of function, right?
Because all of us choose our targets based on dependency and
depth map.
But now we need gain-of-function map to know
where you see those interactions and where it's going to be beneficial.
So all the people that are in the functional genomics area, I
think this is a renaissance for you guys to figure out screens for bringing
together pairs of proteins, and then seeing what effects we can see.
Maybe I'll do the last question myself.
So Nathaniel,
you presented most of these events as unidirectional in terms of
dragging one protein to another. But let's take just the
Ewing sarcoma BCL6 model. Is it possible that each
protein is dragging the other protein to its own loci rather than just ending
up with the Ewing's FLI1 fusion on BCL6 loci?
Do you end up with BCL6 being dragged to Ewing's FLI loci,
and how
might the ligand affinity on each side affect the
relocalization of the protein pairs?
Yeah. No, absolutely. So it's exactly, I think, as you're implying,
through depending on the affinity of the ligands, the relative
abundance of the proteins-
Yeah
... their anchoring KD on chromatin-
... will decide who wins. And then there's some proteins where
a big relocalization has a small effect, and then reciprocally,
with a pioneer transcription factor, a little bit of it getting in can have a
very amplified effect. And so I think that's also
why this is so exciting for a chemical biology approach, because you have to
make the probe and then empirically figure out what wins.
Great. Thanks, Nathaniel. That was
fantastic.Okay,
our next speaker is Brian Liao from Harvard University, who has
done some fantastic work on molecular glue mechanisms and how
they mimic and are mimicked by natural cancer mutations.
So, Brian.
All right. Thank you, Ben, for the introduction, and also congratulations to Steven
on receiving the Next Gen Award. So I'm excited to
show you two recent stories from my lab highlighting an unusual
mechanistic convergence between what we'll call
chemical and genetic glues of an E3 ligase named
KBDBD4. And then I'll talk about some of the implications of this for
induced proximity.
All right, so by way of introduction, my lab specializes in chemical
genetic approaches, where we combine small molecule and genetic
perturbations to study drug target mechanisms.
And this, of course, builds on a long and rich history in the field,
where dissecting the relationships between small molecules and
mutations and their effects on proteins has led to
important biological advances and also
therapeutics development.
For example, finding mutations that confer drug resistance to small
molecules is, of course, a powerful strategy to validate their
on-target specificity and also mechanisms.
And this is critical for oncology drug discovery.
On the other hand, we can also exploit mutations that
permit or enhance small molecule action to actually help us
design selective drugs, such as KRAS inhibitors
that selectively target the G12C mutant allele.
And so these two chemical genetic relationships, suppressors and
enhancers, they have served as the bedrock for these approaches.
But today, I'd like to highlight our serendipitous finding of a new type
of chemical genetic relationship,
what we've been calling convergence.
And what I mean by this is where a small molecule and a mutation can have the exact
same gain of function effect as one another on a protein
target's activity through structural mimicry.
And I'm excited to tell you about this in today's session because I
think this new chemical genetic relationship is a really
interesting paradigm for the field of induced proximity.
And so this story begins with a really interesting small molecule named UM171,
which was originally identified in a phenotypic screen for compounds that can
cause expansion of hematopoietic stem cells.
But despite its widespread use and progression into human clinical trials, the
exact target and mechanism of this compound had remained
elusive. Now, more recently, it was discovered that
UM171 can cause the proteolytic degradation
of CoREST, a transcriptional corepressor, and this somehow
involved a cullin-3 ring ligase named KBDBD4.
Now, this discovery was really exciting because it suggested that
UM171 could be operating as a molecular glue degrader,
taking advantage of a new type of E3 ligase that had never been observed before.
But despite these advances, the exact target and mechanism of
this compound still remained unclear.
And so really intrigued by this, we set out to study its mechanism of action,
and this work was led by Megan, Olivia, and CJ in my lab.
It was a fantastic collaboration with Xiao Wen in Ning Jiang's lab,
as well as many others.
And so when we first embarked on this study, we faced many difficulties in
trying to find the binding site, let alone the target of
UM171, which we assumed was CoREST, the protein that
was directly being degraded.
But this actually turned out to be much more complicated, and for today's talk, I'm
going to jump to the punchline. But it turns out that the actual
target of UM171 was not on anyone's radar
because it's not actually degraded in this mechanism.
But it turned out to be histone deacetylase 1 and 2, what I'll call HDAC for
short, a key partner protein to CoREST.
And with all of those key players identified, we could solve a Cryo-EM
structure with all the components put together.
And what this revealed was that indeed, UM171 acts as a
molecular glue, recruiting this dimeric E3 ligase to
a single copy of HDAC in an asymmetric manner.
And so I think that there are a lot of really interesting insights and
novelties associated with this structure and mechanism since UM171
is the first molecular glue discovered to hijack a dimeric
E3 ligase.
But for today's talk, I'm going to focus on the small molecule
binding site. And so if we zoom in, we see that UM171
partially occupies the active site of HDAC, close to
its catalytic zinc atom. And on the E3 ligase side, it induces a
groove between blade two and three of this kelch propeller
domain.
Now, really what we can tell from this structure is that this small
molecule protein composite surface is really quite extensive.
And based on the complexities of this, at least to me, it's
inconceivable how a molecule like this could have been prospectively designed.
Now, I'd like to point out one key feature in this structure, what is called the
2B2C loop of the ligase, highlighted here in blue.
This loop makes contact not only with UM171, but also
HDAC itself. And so it's a critical interaction hotspot in this ternary
complex interface. Now, I'm pointing out the position of this loop
because it turns out to be a cancer mutation hotspot in
certain subtypes of medulloblastoma.
Now, these cancer mutations are actually quite fascinating.
While they can involve point mutations, what actually is most common in
patients are the in-frame insertion of one or two amino acids into
that loop.
And so when we first started this project, we had no idea what these cancer
mutations were doing.But what we did know was that the
wild-type ligase could somehow degrade coREST by
involving UM171. And so based off of that
connection, we tested the impact of these cancer
mutations on coREST protein levels.
To do this, we engineered a cell line where GFP was knocked into the
endogenous coREST gene, and so we could measure protein levels
using fluorescence.
And what we found using this system, totally unexpected to us at the time,
was that these cancer mutations in the ligase, they could actually
induce coREST degradation even in the absence of
UM171. And so these cancer mutations actually turned
out to be gain-of-function. And while loss-of-function mutations in
the E3 ligases are really well established, this is one of the first
examples of a gain-of-function mutation that can cause the recruitment and
degradation of a new substrate. And I'll call this mechanism
neodegradation for short.
But how is this neodegradation actually taking place?
And so to investigate this mechanism, we first profiled the
landscape of mutations at that 2B2C loop that could
cause this coREST neodegradation using a method called deep
mutational scanning, what I'll call DMS for short.
To do this, we first designed an overexpression library of these
KBDBD4 mutants concentrated along the seven amino
acids of this 2B2C loop. This library could cover all
single amino acid substitutions, all double substitutions of
adjacent residues, as well as all plus one and plus two amino
acid insertions inspired by those cancer variants.
We could then introduce this
KBDBD4 library in a pooled fashion
into that coREST GFP cell line I showed you before, and we could
specifically sort for cells that go GFP dark to identify these
mutations that cause coREST degradation.
Now, at a really high level, it turned out that it's shockingly easy
to cause coREST neodegradation in this system.
And so each dot on this plot shows a different mutation that we could test, over
5,000 of them. And I think what's most striking is that these plus two
insertions shown here in the darkest red, they really work the best by a
long shot. And that matches the fact that they're also the most prevalent
found in these medulloblastomas.
And so to really understand why these plus two insertions are so
effective, especially for the cancer variants, we next solve the
cryo-EM structures of two distinct KBDBD4
mutants bound to the HDAC coREST complex.
We chose what I'll call the PR mutant for short.
This is the most common clinical variant.
It involves the insertion of a proline and arginine residue into that
2B2C loop. We also chose what I'll call TTYML,
a more complex mutation that still results in an overall plus
two.
Now, both of these mutated ligases exhibit a similar
engagement of HDAC to what I showed you before.
And in fact, in one of these E3 ligase protomers, we see that the cancer
insertion, highlighted here in yellow, makes direct contact with the
HDAC active site. So a little bit of deja vu.
If we zoom in here, what we see is that in comparison to the wild-type
ligase overlayed in gray, that the mutants extend
that 2B2C loop into the HDAC active site by creating
a bump on the protein surface. And critically, it's that
central arginine of the PR mutant, which is inserted deep into the
HDAC catalytic pocket, whereas it is the tyrosine in the
corresponding position of TTYML that fulfills that same purpose.
And from our deep mutational scanning, we know that it's that central inserted
residue that's one of the key hotspots driving this
neointeraction. In fact, from our DMS, we actually know all
possible combinations of two amino acids that can essentially fit
into and interact with that pocket.
Now, I think what's really curious here is that
UM171 also contacts this 2B2C loop,
as well as the HDAC active site. And so what's its relationship to these
cancer insertions?
If we actually superimpose these two structures on top of one another,
what we see is that the cancer insertion and the small molecule, they
actually exactly mimic one another, not only functionally,
but also structurally, through, again, what I'll call chemical genetic
convergence. And so I think this is really striking, and so I'll walk
you through this step by step.
And so we can imagine that UM171, it has these three different arms in
its structure. The first arm, this diamino
cyclohexane, it makes polar contacts with these two acidic
residues in HDAC, aspartate 99, glutamate 98.
And that's just like threonine 311 in the TTYML mutant.
The second arm, the tetrazole, is inserted deep into the HDAC active site,
in this case resembling that central tyrosine and arginine of the cancer
insertion.
And lastly, this third arm, the benzyl group, in this case resembles
methionine 313. And so these three arms of
UM171, these different functional groups, they actually mirror the
different side chains of the amino acid
insertions. So in essence, the wild-type ligase and
HDAC, they have this imperfect interface, which allows for
weak
basal interaction, but it's not good enough for degradation to
happen. These cancer insertions provide a bump on the ligase
surface that can fill in the adjacent hole made up by the HDAC
active site. And it's those bump hole interactions that
glue together this otherwise suboptimal interface.
And that's exactly analogous to the mechanism of action of
UM171, showing that the mechanism of a small
molecule, molecular glue, and what we'll call a cancer
mutation genetic glue, in this case, can actually work through the same
principles.And so altogether, we could
reveal these converging mechanisms of this gain-of-function cancer
mutation in an E3 ligase and the mechanism of a
small molecule molecular gludegrader, UM171, showing that they
work as molecular facsimiles of one another.
But taking a step back, I think this highlights a really interesting
case where genetics and a mutation could
actually reveal a glueable hotspot, a genetic
glue on a E3 ligase surface, whose
effects could be exactly recapitulated by the engagements of a small
molecule through this chemical genetic convergence.
And I think this raises a really interesting thought experiment.
If we knew everything about that cancer mutation, the deep
mutational scanning data, the cryo-EM structures, but we
knew nothing about UM171, could we have actually
harnessed that data to perspectively design a molecular glue?
And so along those lines, I think what's very fascinating is that both of these
modalities, the small molecule and the mutation, they're both
neomorphic. They confer hyperactivation on an E3 ligase.
And beyond the context of medulloblastoma or hematopoietic stem
cells, hyperactivation of KBDBD4 is actually
cytotoxic to most cells. And so in unpublished data, we
have shown that UM171 in the broad prism screen
is broadly anti-proliferative in many human cancer cell lines.
Likewise, we have seen that overexpression of this mutant
E3 ligase can also block the growth of many human
cancer cell lines through what we'll call an activation lethality.
This led us to wonder, could we actually use this activation
lethality phenotype in a cell death readout to
identify these gain-of-function mutations on these ligases,
these genetic glues, that might actually go after new
neosubstrates?
And so with that in mind, to explore this, we could conduct that deep
mutational scanning of the 2B2C loop,
just like I showed you before. But instead of only measuring co-REST
degradation, we could also read out cell proliferation
and drop out due to this activation lethality.
And so the data is shown on your right.
The x-axis shows us just co-REST degradation, the exact data
that I showed you before. But now the y-axis is showing
us the cell proliferation associated with each of these mutants,
and also dropout due to this activation lethality.
And so mutants in the lower right-hand corner, these are very effective at
degrading co-REST and also essentially killing these cells,
actually revealing that the two activities are correlated.
And just as we expected, we see that the cancer mutants, which are very
potent, reside in this lower right-hand corner.
And so I think what this highlights is how we can use this activation lethality
phenotype in a cell death readout to identify
these genetic glues of E3 ligases, even
without knowing the substrate that's being degraded.
And so based on these results, we've been having a lot of fun using deep
mutational scanning to find these glueable
hotspots, these genetic glues of E3s, and also the
neosubstrates associated with them.
And so first, we can conduct this high-throughput mutational scanning
across the surface of these E3 ligase substrate receptors.
And we can then take essentially this library of bumped variants and
select them in different cell-based phenotypic readouts,
with the idea that we can identify these, again, rare
gain-of-function genetic glues that might actually go after
new neosubstrates.
I showed you how we could use readouts like degradation of specific targets
or cell proliferation, but there are many ways that we can imagine this.
And through proteomics, we can actually identify these neosubstrates involved.
Now, I think the outstanding question, the million-dollar question, is
whether you can actually replace this genetic glue, this bump
on the protein surface, with a small molecule.
And as chemical biologists, these are questions that we're actively exploring,
and we hope to report on this in due time.
So that brings me to this presentation's most important slide.
I, of course, have to thank everyone who did all of the work involved, our really
fantastic collaborators, Xiao Wen in Ning's lab, as well as many others.
I have to thank our funding sources and acknowledge my disclosures.
Thank you for attention. I'll stop here. I'm happy to take any questions.
Okay, questions. I will
start if I can. Great. Okay, so
fascinating concept that,
if I understood it correctly,
you might posit that insertions of one or two amino acids might be more
effective at creating surface neomorphic outcomes that
promote degradation than just missense mutation. Is that a fair statement or no?
Yeah, that's definitely a fair statement.
For us, we found that these insertions were most effective.
And actually, insertions have been more rarely studied.
Yeah.
But of the reports coming out from, for example, Ben Leonard's lab and
others, it seems like they're more privileged at promoting these
gain-of-function interactions.
Very interesting.
And so I think prioritizing them makes a lot of sense.
And is it right so far, your approach you're taking is somewhat random at the amino
acids you insert, or do you have a logic?
Yeah, I think right now we're just taking an approach of trying
everything, even though it's a bit bigger in terms of mutation space that we need
to explore. But one could definitely think about prioritizing
hydrophobic amino acids or even unnatural amino acids
in the future.
Great. Thanks.
A really nice talk. I'm just interested in actually using your
UM17 to actually displace in the mutant setting.
So can you actually now restore
the death effect in the mutant
case of the ligase?
Yeah, no, that's an excellent question.
So what we found was, so UM17-1,
interestingly, can actually cooperate with the cancer mutations to some extent.
But
what we noticed, of course, was that it's really the HDAC active site that's a
critical interaction hotspot. And so what we found was that HDAC
active site inhibitors could actually block that interaction.
Mm-hmm.
I think actually what would be more ideal is if one had ligands for the
ligase side, since then you would not have an HDAC inhibitor.
But as a proof of concept, that worked really well to restore
levels of that co-res protein complex.
Thanks.
Great talk.
Thought it was pretty interesting that the mutation that actually shows
up, at least one of them, is positively charged, and a lot of-
Yeah
... a lot of active site HDAC binders are negatively charged.
I guess that's probably a surprise to you guys as well.
Do you understand what's going on there?
Yeah.
So that insertion of an arginine, or even the arginine seemed to be
very privileged. Even a point mutation that put an
arginine into that pocket was very effective.
We thought that what might be going on, we did not have the resolution to see it,
was that since it's a zinc deacetylase,
that there should be an active site water that's critical in the mechanism.
And so,
our hypothesis was that it was forming some sort of interaction there.
But until we actually resolve that, this is just speculation.
Okay, thanks a lot.
Okay, Brian, thanks a bunch. That was really excellent.
As
Brian mentioned, our next speaker, Steven Corsello from Stanford, is one of
the NextGen stars, and so congratulations,
Steven, on that recognition from the AACR.
And he's going to tell us some really interesting work about the relationship
between E3 ligase and nuclear pore protein degradation. Steven.
Great. Well, thank you so much, Dr.
Krivat, and thank you to the AACR for this recognition.
My lab uses systematic cellular-based assays in order to identify
drug mechanisms and cancer vulnerabilities.
And starting when I was at the Broad Institute, we launched an effort to first
collect the active ingredient from as many drugs tested in humans
as possible, and then profile that library across its
different phenotypic readouts.
One of those approaches that has proven to be the most fruitful for finding
anti-cancer mechanisms has been systematic cell viability profiling.
And we accomplish this using the prism pooled screening strategy,
where individual cancer cell lines are first labeled with unique DNA
barcode sequences. And this allows us to pool the models
together and much more efficiently test compounds for signs
of anti-cancer activity. We use the barcodes as a surrogate for cell
viability and then compare the barcode abundance in treated versus
control wells. And we initially reported a
data set of more than 4,000 drugs across more than
500 cancer cell lines in order to define the initial drug
response landscape of human cancer cell lines.
And you'll see that at this high-level 2D representation of the drug
activity profiles, drugs do tend to cluster
by their known targets and mechanisms.
We were most interested, though, in hunting for compounds with new
patterns of anti-cancer activity, and we found several dozen
compounds acting in unexpected ways.
And a lot of our interest has been taking those compounds back to the lab and
figuring out how they work. And in general, they've tended to work in
modes of action beyond enzyme inhibition.
So it seems like these phenotypic approaches can help enrich for interesting
mechanisms, including some of the gain-of-function pharmacology that we've learned
about during this session.
In order to get a start in identifying the targets of these compounds,
we take a predictive modeling approach.
Since these cell lines have been extensively characterized by the Cancer Cell Line
Encyclopedia project, we can systematically compare the
molecular features, such as which genes are high or low, which copy number events
have occurred, or what mutations are present in the cells.
And we compare those against all of the drug activity profiles through
random forest predictive modeling.
And this yields a set of predictive models along with features and
feature weights. And in some cases, this has given us strong initial
insight into how these compounds might be acting.
Most recently, we've used these types of screening approaches in order to
look for new therapeutic opportunities in difficult-to-treat cancers.
And one of the most difficult remains pancreatic adenocarcinoma, and this
is a disease I treat in the clinic. There are over 50,000 deaths per
year from pancreatic cancer in the United States alone.
And our mainstay of therapy for patients with advanced disease remains
cytotoxic chemotherapy regimens.
And even with our most aggressive combination of three chemotherapy drugs, a
regimen called FOLFIRINOX, the median overall survival remains just
around one year. We're quite excited about reports at this meeting
and likely some targeted therapies coming soon.
I think it remains clear that we really will need multiple targets in order to
achieve more cures in this disease.
So a postdoc in my group, Linji Wan, began to look for new
therapeutic opportunities, and we came across a drug that had been
in phase one testing, known as PRLX 93936.
And across all of the cell lines testedIt was more likely
to inhibit pancreas and head and neck cancer cell models versus the
other cancer types tested in this experiment.
In addition, there was a strong predictive biomarker.
We found that expression of an E3 ligase called TRIM21
strongly predicted sensitivity, and you'll see if you look at all of the
cell lines, the cell lines that had high expression by RNA seq of
TRIM21 were more likely to be sensitive to this
compound.
The compound had a really interesting development history.
It was first synthesized about 20 years ago by a company named Prolexis
Pharmaceuticals, and their initial goal was to take this tool
compound on the left, a compound called erastin, which is
famous for being the prototypic inducer of a form of programmed
cell death called ferroptosis. They tried to turn erastin into a clinical
drug, and through medicinal chemistry optimization, they succeeded in
making it more potent and more drug-like.
But there was a big catch. In the course of the optimization, they actually
changed the mechanism of action, so it was no longer acting through
ferroptosis, but instead was killing cancer cells
through a traditional form of programmed cell death, apoptosis.
Despite not knowing the target, this was advanced into two phase I trials
where they generated some initial safety data.
But ultimately, the program was abandoned, and the compound was put on the
shelf.
So we took this into the lab and started just by confirming that the pooled
screening result could be reproduced by testing individual cell lines.
We selected these cell lines based on their TRIM21 status, and indeed, all
of the TRIM21 expressing cell lines were sensitive, and cell
lines with low TRIM21 expression were completely resistant,
thus recapitulating the prism screening result.
We were then interested to identify functional mediators of response
to this drug, PRLX, and we did this using a functional genomic strategy where
we took a pancreatic cancer cell line, derivatized it to express a
Cas9 protein, and then transduced these cells with genome-scale guide RNA
libraries. We then cultured that mixture of genetic perturbation in
the presence of the compound for several weeks, and then looked for gene level
perturbations that could rescue from the compound or sensitize.
In our initial CRISPR knockout screen, we found that the top hit
across the entire genome that recognized from this drug was
TRIM21 as well. So it was not only a predictive biomarker, it's actually
the top functional mediator.
In addition, we did a screen in the opposite direction using CRISPR activation,
where we overexpressed every gene in the genome.
And there, one of the top sensitization hits was TRIM21.
So this phenotype actually works in both directions.
Several other hits in the screen included multiple mediators of
NF Kappa B and interferon signaling.
We then tested individual cell lines.
So what happens if we perturb TRIM expression?
And here we found if we take a TRIM21 expressing line and knock out
TRIM21, there's a complete rescue from response to the
compound, whereas with erastin, that original parent compound, there's absolutely
no shift. And then we also could take TRIM21 low cell
lines that were resistant to the compound, overexpress
TRIM21, and confer sensitivity. So this turned out to be a really nice
binary phenotype for further study.
So TRIM21 is a really unique ring family E3
ubiquitin ligase that serves as a bridge between innate and
adaptive immunity. Its native function has actually been shown
to be to bind intracellular antibodies, and this is
mediated through an interaction between the TRIM21 PRI SPry domain
and the FC region of IgG antibodies.
Upon binding an antibody often bound to a pathogen
inside of a cell, this leads to ubiquitylation and
proteasome-mediated degradation of that large cargo,
and TRIM appears to be particularly evolved to degrade large multimeric
substrates. This also activates interferon signaling
within cells. So by some measures, this might actually be an immune
sensor as well. So we then hypothesized
that TRIM21 might actually be the direct molecular target of
this drug, PRLX. And to begin to figure this out, we also used a
mutational scanning approach using CRISPR base editing, where we tiled the
entire coding sequence of TRIM21 with guide RNAs, and we found
that the rescuing mutations tended to cluster at three different
sites, one of which was at the natural substrate
recognition domain of TRIM21, which coincided in the crystal
structure with the location of a shallow binding
pocket. So we hypothesized that the PRI SPry domain was the
direct target of this molecule.
We then expressed recombinant TRIM21 PRI SPry and
succeeded in obtaining a ligand-bound crystal structure of a PRLX
analog. This allowed us to confirm that the base editing result was
correct, and it also showed us the direct amino acid
interactions between TRIM21 and
this compound. And then using both our isogenic cell line
system as well as the structural information later on,
we were able to team up with our neighbors at Stanford, in Nathaniel Gray's
lab, to establish the structure activity relationship of
this compound series against TRIM21.
And through the synthesis of many chemical analogs, we
succeeded in both improving the potency as well as dramatically
improving the
properties of these molecules. The original drug was administered intravenously
in the clinic on what might've been a suboptimal schedule.
And now we have the opportunity to actually give these agents orally.
And then this compound shown on the right, JWZ8103,
also helped enable our biochemical assays in order to figure out the
mechanism of action. It turned out having a more potent compound early on was
quite helpful in that regard.So now we
had an example of an E3 ligase whose
expression is essential for response to this compound.
We next asked whether this might be another example of targeted
protein degradation. And to begin to study this, we performed
three different proteomic experiments.
We looked at changes in protein abundance.
We also looked for changes in ubiquitin marks on proteins through
diglycine remnant profiling. And finally, we developed a proximity
labeling approach using TurboID to look if this molecule was actually
inducing changes in the TRIM21 interactome.
And it turned out that all three of these proteomic experiments led us to the
same targets, which were multiple components of the nuclear
pore complex, this large multimeric substrate that
serves as the gateway between the cytoplasm and nucleus.
And we saw that many, almost all of the nucleoporins were
labeled in the TurboID experiment, were ubiquitinated, and
were subsequently degraded in a
TRIM21-dependent manner. We saw no proteins degraded
in cells with TRIM21 knockout.
We were also able to assess this on a single-cell level.
This is an immunofluorescence image of pancreatic cancer cells.
And here, if we treat with the molecular glue for eight hours, we see
loss of nuclear pore expression along the nuclear membrane.
And importantly, we did not see any loss of expression with
TRIM21 knockout.
So then the next question was: How is TRIM21 actually recruited
to the nuclear pore complex? And to begin to understand this, we actually
went back to our original CRISPR screen and realized we'd overlooked something
initially when we looked at the results summarized at the gene level.
It turned out that one of the four guides against the nucleoporin
Nup98 that's present in the Brunello library actually
rescued from the compound, whereas the other guides were actually depleted because
this is an essential gene. And we found that the single active guide
targeted a special spot on the gene that encodes
something called the autoproteolytic domain.
It turns out that Nup98 and Nup96 are encoded as one polypeptide
precursor. It gets cleaved at this site to generate the
mature protein forms.
Then we transduced cells with that guide alone and found that that was
actually enough to also completely rescue from
these TRIM21-directed compounds, suggesting that the
Nup98 APD was the key
site of interaction with TRIM21.
We then assessed for direct molecular glue interaction using several approaches,
and were able to show that TRIM21 directly binds
Nup98 in cells with a NanoBit reporter assay.
Here we found that compound rank order nicely agreed with
their cellular cytotoxicity. And we were also able to
recapitulate this interaction in vitro through TR-FRET
experiments where we expressed recombinant Nup98 APD.
And we had similar results using SPR as well.
So these compounds are indeed molecular glues that directly recruit
TRIM21 to Nup98.
They also appear to have potent anticancer properties.
And as had been originally reported 20 years ago, they do induce
apoptosis through the intrinsic pathway.
We see a robust activation of a Caspase reporter within 12 hours of
treatment. This also occurs in a TRIM21-dependent manner.
Next, given how important nuclear transport is in gene expression
to export mature mRNAs from the nucleus to
cytoplasm,
we hypothesized that maybe these molecules in part act
by decreasing the expression of proteins that cancers need for
survival. And we'd indeed already seen some hints of this in our
proteomic data. But we found that proteins that are
famous for having short cellular half-lives, like MCL1 and
MYC, are dramatically reduced upon degradation of the nuclear
pore complex in cancer cells. And at the mRNA level,
we're able to see this, for example, for MCL1.
Within four hours of compound treatment, cytoplasmic MCL1
goes down, or as it actually goes up within the nucleus, likely
because those mRNAs can no longer be exported
out of the nucleus themselves.
Then specific to pancreatic cancer, a quick summary of the
mechanism. So these molecules, we believe, directly bind
TRIM21, which is then recruited to the nuclear pore
complex through an interaction with Nup98.
And then this leads to labeling of the NPC with ubiquitin
marks. This is then degraded in a proteasome-dependent manner,
which disrupts nucleocytoplasmic transport and then results
in apoptotic cancer cell death.
And then specific to pancreatic cancer, we went on to test patient-derived models
and PDOs in vitro. And there, TRIM21
expression predicted their sensitivity.
And we also saw encouraging evidence in cell line xenograft studies.
And these are two different KRAS mutant cancer cell lines.
And in both models, we saw robust efficacy,
especially for an optimized derivative, this JWZ compound
again, where just after several days of daily dosing, we saw
immediate tumor regressions in these mice,
suggesting that this could be a valuable approach for future
development.
There remain, though, really two unanswered questions, and the first is: Well,
what is the therapeutic index really for targeting nuclear transport
in cancer versus normal cells? And this remains an area of active
investigation, though we certainly learned a lot from literature reports,
including some evidence that genetic depletion of the nuclear
pore complex more affects cancer cells versus normal
cells. And inspired by this and other work, we're now
doingComparing the sensitivity of cancer cells versus immortalized
normal cancer cells, where we exposed them to TRIM21 glues for
defined periods. Here is just one example where if we treat for
24 hours, we see about a 23-fold shift in the
sensitivity between PANCS-1 cells and
hTERT-RPE-1 cells.
A second unaddressed question remains, well, multiple
groups have really performed pioneering work over the past several years
showing that there's a range of different compounds that
can induce a TRIM21 glue interaction.
And it's actually somewhat surprising how different these compounds are, and they
can all induce gluing between TRIM21 and NUP98.
So what really explains why this exists
in nature,
and to date, we'd only really had structural insight to the
TRIM21 side of the equation, which was quite limiting.
So working together with Stephen Hinshaw at Stanford, we recently succeeded
in solving the ternary complex between
TRIM21 and the NUP98 APE, and there's a number of really interesting
features here. One is that the NUP98 surface itself,
perhaps like we've seen with other molecular glues, is relatively indistinct
and flat in nature, and not something that you might have predicted through
computational methods as having been the binding site.
And while we do see direct interactions between the compound
and NUP98, it actually seems like most of the
interaction is really mediated through protein-protein contacts,
and there's an extensive network of these contacts.
One example is shown here on the right.
And we think that this will have important implications for both further
optimization of these compounds, but also in efforts to
reprogram TRIM21 against other substrates in order to take advantage of
its preference for large multimeric substrates.
So in conclusion, we found that TRIM21 molecular glues have potent
efficacy against pancreatic cancer models.
We've been able to establish their mechanism of action using multiple orthogonal
approaches. And our next steps are really focused on determining the
preclinical therapeutic index, further in vivo evaluation,
and advancing these molecules in development.
So I'd like to thank everyone in my group and all of our outstanding collaborators,
both at Stanford and at the Broad Institute.
And thank you all for your attention.
I'd be delighted to answer any questions.
That was a great talk. Shiva Malik from Novartis.
I noticed IRF2 was a hit in your screens,
and I was just thinking an alternative or potentially
a mechanism that might also be happening is you're actually blocking
degradation of another substrate. So did you look for that?
IRF2 being one, but potentially maybe there's other substrates that are blocked and
that's actually what's causing the cell death versus what you're seeing.
Yeah. Thank you for the question. It's a fascinating idea.
I think the IRF1 and 2 link here turns out to be quite interesting, and I
think they turn out to actually be both upstream and downstream of
TRIM21, which has made studying them a little harder.
We do know that when we knock out IRF2, that also completely rescues from this
mechanism. However, one reason is TRIM21 expression actually
goes down.
Mm.
And IRF1 and 2 drive expression of TRIM21.
But that being said, when we treat with the glues, the first gene to go up is IRF1,
which then itself gets degraded in a proteasome-mediated manner.
So there seems to be a really closely evolved feedback loop within
cells involving these IRF1 and 2 signaling proteins.
But I think it actually could be quite interesting to think about proteomics-based
approaches there as well in the setting of IRF1 or 2 loss.
So following up actually on the expression levels of TRIM21.
So,
the expression level of TRIM21 varies quite widely across
cancers. So you can imagine that you won't be able to use this
molecular glue in all settings. So can you actually learn any
insights from that molecular glue that you can use to target the nuclear
pore using more ubiquitously expressed ligases?
Yes, and absolutely. I think that part of the selectivity here could in part
come from the TRIM21 expression pattern.
It does tend to be highly expressed, especially when
comparing cancer versus matched normal tissue, higher in
pancreas and head and neck cancers in general.
So I do think that cell line observation will hold up.
We are interested in looking at primary patient tumors and kind
of defining that strategy now in order to really better understand its expression
pattern. But at least some of the selectivity will hopefully come from the
expression pattern.
And great talk, by the way.
Thank you.
Hi there. There are companies looking at TRIM TACS
that they're using to degrade CNS aggregates for
neurodegenerative diseases. Have you looked at your compounds in
neurodegenerative aggregates and clearing of those?
Yeah, so that's an area of active work right now, and I think a number of those
efforts are quite exciting and I think are taking advantage of what's been shown to
be a rather unique avidity-driven amplification
mechanism around TRIM21. The fact that it could degrade the entire
NPC is quite special. So I think that there's a lot of opportunity
there. I think some of the rules around TRIM21 PROTAC
design still remain to be established.
And right now, there's a lot of interest in figuring out what the best TRIM
recruiter is going to be. One interesting thing I think
explained by the crystal structure now is that the monovalent binding of
many of these ligands for TRIM21 is actually relatively weak.
Okay.
So the protein-protein interaction does a lot of that lifting.
So I think it remains to be seen if a glue-based approach, taking advantage of
complementary protein surfaces will ultimately be the most potent efficacious,
or if bivalent PROTACs will really work out.
But I think there is some initial proof of concept work that at least shows it's
feasible. And I hope it'll be something that can be translated.
Thank you.
Last question.Hi, nice work.
TRIM21 is very good, as you said, at getting multimeric proteins.
Does it work on NUP98 only in the context of the nuclear pore, or does it
also work on the NUP98 in various NUP98-driven fusions?
That's a really interesting question and something we want to look at as well.
It turns out the majority of the NUP98 fusions seen in
pediatric leukemia actually lack the APDE.
Yeah.
They're proximal to that in the gene sequence, with a few
exceptions. So we don't expect that the molecular glue will
directly engage many of those fusions.
But there certainly are some interesting reports of NUP98's activity
within the nucleus, perhaps even separate from the nuclear pore complex.
So that's something that we're currently looking into.
Thanks, Steven. That was fantastic.
Thank you.
Okay. Our final speaker is Fleur Ferguson from
locally here at UCSD on one of my favorite topics,
the proximity de-induced degradation of the druggable proteome.
So,
Fleur.
Thank you so much for the introduction.
I'm really excited to be here and tell you about how my lab is
thinking about developing induced proximity modalities
and share a few vignettes of how powerful it can be to take these
systems-level approaches.
So I'll start with my disclosures.
And the question that we're really interested in as a lab
that's a chemical biology lab, but at its core is really
interested in doing the medicinal chemistry of chemical biology to
create chemical tools that can enable
us to validate new targets, and in particular, validate pharmacological
modulation of new targets in a way that allows
us to pursue them therapeutically.
But also look at some of these proteins that come out of screens
or that come out of genetic studies that are perhaps not very well annotated.
And those of you who have done that will know that it's a surprising number of
proteins.
And so one of the big questions, if you're thinking about these
problems and you're in the field of induced proximity, and one that you might
be asking yourself, having seen all of the amazing work in both this session
as well as the chemistry to the clinic sessions this weekend, are
how do you match your target and your
indication to the right induced proximity modality?
If you've determined that a simple, well, not simple, but if you've determined that
a traditional inhibitor is not what you need, how do you
know if you can indeed create a molecular glue?
What type of molecular glue, gain-of-function or loss-of-function pharmacology
would you want? And then how do you know that any hits or leads you may
get are advanceable, and how can you advance them quickly to really
prove that this mechanism is the right one for you?
Because even though we are all really excited about the space, the
space is very new.
And so something that my lab has
invested a lot of time in is creating profiling
experiments. So these agnostic, unbiased experiments using
predominantly chemo proteomics to try and understand
which types of proteins go together and how these different modalities work.
So one example is how do we understand how to
find molecular glues that do not lead to degradation
using proteomic approaches that are ligand-centric.
So come from the small molecule and don't require knowledge of the target.
These pair very well with the beautiful functional genomics approaches that we've
seen previously.
And so one example of this is ligand-guided proximity labeling, which
allows you to create interactome maps of your small molecule and detect
these transient and weakly bound complexes that are assembled in a novel
way.
Another thing we can do is use these types of approaches, including
degradation screening, as well as small molecule interactome screening and
PTM screening, to create these maps of
pharmacology. And these large-scale maps are not only useful for telling
us where do we start and what's the low-hanging fruit for each modality.
But they also allow us to team up with colleagues in the machine learning space
to understand both protein and small molecule intrinsic features that will
help us predict the drug ability, degradability, or
even glue ability of our future targets.
And so from this work, we can start to get a picture of what types
of molecules might be best for targets of
interest.
Once we get to this point, which I think is a point where we often
feel great about ourselves until we have to actually optimize the
molecules to make them potent and selective, we can again turn
back to our old friend, multi-proteomic methodologies,
in order to create experimentally validated mathematical
models where we can profile using omic technologies things like
target engagement, ternary complex formation,
ubiquitination kinetics, and degradation kinetics, in the example of
degraders. And, of course, for other gain-of-function or loss-of-function
modalities do the same thing in order to both
map out experimentally how each of these features go
together and then put that back to validate the mathematical
models of how we think these modalities are working in the cell, which may tell us
some gaps, may also tell us what we get right.
But ultimately, we can use those to fine-tune what features are the
ones that are having an outsize effect on compound potency,
compound efficacy, and target space, and use those predictive models to
guide our first and second round of library generation.
But then also to allow us this more rational
way to advance those molecules going from a weak hit or a
hit we pull out of a screen to something that's more potent
and selective and looks much more like a tool compound that you would want to use
to validate your target or modality of
interest.We also try to hasten our path
to proof of concept in in vivo models, aware that many of these models that
we use in the dish
are fantastic for a first round. But then when we get
to things like resistance, when we get to things like more complex mechanisms,
we often want to use either patient-derived models that are hard to
manipulate or in vivo models. And there we've come up with a
number of pro-drug and pro-moiety
strategies in order to, for example, enhance distribution across the blood-brain
barrier and get to those proof of principle experiments as quickly as
possible in order to pharmacologically validate new therapeutic
hypotheses come up with by our biological collaborators.
So we spend a lot of time doing this type of mapping, trying to
think globally about when someone comes to us with a challenge or
comes to us with an exciting new academic discovery, how can we be best
prepared to take the most strategic path forward?
And I wanted to share
in this talk some vignettes from a particular
collaboration that we've had in our cancer center with Andy Lowy, one of our heads
of surgery, who is interested in a topic I think many of us
are interested in, which is the development of resistance to these next
generation RAS inhibitors and how we're able to leverage a lot of this
knowledge in order to rapidly create tool compounds for highly
understudied proteins.
And so the challenge that our collaborators came to us with, which is one that's
being discussed today, is that pancreatic cancers of
course have a high prevalence of KRAS
mutation. However, there have been, dating back a long
time, this
challenge that KRAS is not the only way that pancreatic cancer
cells can survive. And so this is old data showing that
ablation of KRAS G12D in a murine GEM model
allowed these persister cells with a high oxidative
phosphorylation rate to survive.
This was kind of later shown through multiple studies,
a nice one here from Joe Mancias' lab, taking cancer cell
lines that have KRAS mutations,
so these pancreatic cancer cells, and culturing them for a long time
in kind of sub-lethal doses of various KRAS inhibitors.
In this particular paper, they were looking at sotorasib
and figuring out how does the proteome change over that time?
What are the changes that are leading to resistance?
And many of the pathways that came out turned out to be the TCA cycle,
pyruvate metabolism, again suggesting this metabolic switch that's
allowing the cells to tolerate that KRAS loss.
And later work has shown that this can happen in both in vivo
models, that this happens across multiple different KRAS
mutations and across multiple different drugs.
And so here's one nice example, where they looked in
vivo at how the population of the cancer cells are
changing following exposure to a KRAS G12D
inhibitor. And what they found was that these populations were shifting from a
classical and mesenchymal phenotype to a new
subtype, which they called PEMT, where again, you see one of the
major hallmarks is this upregulation of oxidative phosphorylation
programs allowing a switch in cellular metabolism.
And so this isn't the only path to resistance, but it seems to be one that
occurs across mutations and across different drugs.
And so it was one that we were interested in probing.
And so, I think we all are really excited about KRAS inhibitors, and we're
also really aware that we want to sustain and enable their effects in
pancreatic cancer cells so we can go beyond extra months
of life towards a cure.
And one of the challenges when you have a change in metabolism towards
oxidative phosphorylation are that there are multiple cell types
that, in the human body, are very dependent on active OXPHOS,
and those are things like neurons as well as muscle cells.
And so this is one example, which was a beautiful study, where they
really published as well a really nice post hoc analysis of their phase one,
so were very transparent in all the mechanism and data, showing that
complex I inhibitors look actually great until you get into the
clinic. And then in these high oxidative phosphorylation cancers,
you end up having these unfortunate adverse effects, these
high-grade adverse effects that cause patients to have to come off the study, and
that was largely peripheral neuropathy.
And so one of the challenges that we were faced with, or that our collaborators
were faced with and wanted to address, was how do we identify these
rheostats, these kind of
transcriptional or translational programmers that
allow cancer cells to suddenly and sustainably change their
normal metabolic state to one of high oxidative phosphorylation, but are not
responsible for basal processing or basal oxidative
phosphorylation that's happening all the time in our neurons.
So can we identify those rheostats and then can we drug them?
And one of the candidates that came out of our collaborators' analysis was a
transcription factor called ZBTB11, which at that time had only
really been studied in depth in murine ES cells,
and there were only, I think, a couple of papers really describing its function.
Nevertheless, this protein actually is a low abundance protein, but its
levels do go up during the development of resistance to multiple different
KRAS inhibitors in culture. And we were able to
use CRISPR-I knockdown effects to demonstrate that the
reported genes or the reported regulatory
transcriptional programs that were happening in the published
studies in murine ES cells were also happening in our resistant cancer
cells. And this was a downregulation of mitochondrial biogenesis and
mitochondrial ribosome genes. And so we reasoned that there may be a higher
dependence in rapidly proliferating cancer cells that have to
rapidly expand and repopulate their
mitochondria that may give us some therapeutic
index.We were also able to validate that
in our kind of cancer cells that had become resistant to these
various KRAS inhibitors,
that they had increased basal and maximal oxidative phosphorylation,
and you can see that on this seahorse plot here, and that if we knock down
ZBTB11 using CRISPR-I, that it's broadly well-tolerated but
does re-normalize or reduce the basal and
maximal oxidative phosphorylation, really changing the metabolic index of these
cancer cells back to something more like that KRAS
inhibitor-naive state.
We can use CRISPR-I to also look at the
combination effects, and so if we knock down ZBTB11 in the
parent cells, it's well-tolerated.
If we knock down ZBTB11 in the sotorasib-resistant cells and
combine that with the sotorasib that we already have in the media, we see
these nice additive effects where we have very nice control or even
inhibition of these resistant cells population,
suggesting to us that combating this adaptive metabolic
program would be able to resensitize the cells to KRAS
inhibitors and allow for more sustained efficacy of those
inhibitors.
So the challenge was then to find
what's the right modality and how can we access
that rapidly in order to create a tool compound for a brand-new kind of
target coming out of these new mechanisms.
And what we noted was that ZBTB11 is a C2H2 zinc
finger transcription factor that has this
CXXCG motif that's typical of
transcription factors that have been targeted with IMID-like molecules that bind to
cereblon. And if we look at in-house libraries, we saw one very
lonely hit, and you can see it's a weak hit, and we have multiple off-targets,
and this corresponded to about 20% downregulation at 10
micromolar. So we had our work cut out for us.
Nevertheless, since we had an initial hit,
we performed a HiBIT knock-in into those resistant cells
and then screened a focused library of analogs, which again,
you'll see had an extremely low hit rate and many of these didn't validate.
However, the one hit that did validate, we were able to rapidly
progress doing a relatively minimal medicinal chemistry campaign of
about 50 additional analogs and our initial screen being around
250 analogs of that first hit. And the SAR is
described in this "J. Med. Chem." paper.
So our compounds that we came up with don't necessarily look like molecules that
would be fantastic for an in vivo experiment, but they are great cellular tool
compounds. And we created an active degrader molecular glue,
JWJ-0136, as well as a negative
control that no longer binds to cereblon, and a negative control that can
bind to cereblon but no longer recruits ZBTB11 into a ternary
complex to induce its degradation.
We could show that we have really nice degradation of ZBTB11 with a
Dmax of around 80%, and that this is
time-dependent. It's dependent on the proteasome, it's
dependent on the activity of cereblon, and it's dependent on
engagement of that cereblon binding site.
We showed that we had a
small number of off-targets, so ZBTB21, a very close homolog of
ZBTB11, as well as ZFP91 and WIZ, which are commonly
degraded by these cereblon glues.
And so we needed a way to actually make sure that our transcriptional,
translational, proteome-wide, and
metabolomic profiling effects
were really through the ZBTB11. And so we needed to come
up with another gold standard, which is a
degradation-resistant mutant that would rescue ZBTB11
from our drug. To do so, we performed degron mapping and then modeled
the ternary complex, where we saw this lysine 866
was having a lot of nice interactions with our
CF3 functionalized phenyl ring. And we were able to,
using a cellular BRET assay, show that whilst our
molecule, but not the negative controls, form a nice ternary complex in
cells between cereblon and ZBTB11.
If we mutate this lysine, we're
able to completely rescue that ternary complex formation, leading to a
complete rescue of degradation. And so with our chemical and genetic
tools in hand, we were ready to examine the role of ZBTB11 across a
number of different pancreatic cancer contexts.
We wanted to first verify that our molecules were able to effectively
recapitulate the CRISPR-I knockdown effects, and so we did
RNA-seq, we did proteomic profiling at three- and
five-day, and we did metabolomic profiling, and what you can see
is that we have very rapid changes in the transcriptome as early as five
hours in many of these same pathways, including mitochondrial
biogenesis and mitochondrial ribosome biogenesis.
If we do proteome-wide studies to look at how our
cancer cells are responding to the long-term
treatment with these KRAS inhibitor drugs and how our
small molecule degraders can change those kind of
proteome-wide states, what we can see is if we
do K-mean clustering analysis, for example, following five days of treatment,
we can see that sotorasib dramatically increases, for example,
clusters that are enriched in protein sets responsible for
ATP
synthesis and the electron transport chain, explaining some of this increased
oxidative phosphorylation, and our small molecule degraders are able to
normalize this and bring them back to the KRAS inhibitor-naive
state.
Again, metabolomics-wise, we're able to see a reduction in the TCA
cycle and pyruvate metabolism, as well as a number of other changes suggesting
that we have really forced that metabolic program back into its
original state.This leads to significant functional
changes. So what we can see here, in a sea horse assay, in our
resistant cells, we have a dramatic reduction in basal and maximal
oxidative phosphorylation, leading to a significant change in the
metabolic index of these cells. And this can be
rescued with our negative controls and can also be rescued by add
back of the degradation-resistant mutant ZBTB11, but not the wild
type ZBTB11, demonstrating that these effects are on target.
We can see beautiful combination effects across a number of different
KRAS inhibitor resistant cell lines.
So these are pancreatic cancer cells that have been made resistant to
G12C inhibitors, G12D inhibitors, or more
recently, we have the pan RAS on inhibitor resistant cells too.
And you can see these nice combinations where you see resistance to the parent
inhibitor that is overcome with the combination of
ZBTB11 degradation. Importantly, this too is
rescued by add back of the degradation-resistant mutant, but not
by add back of the wild type ZBTB11.
And more critically, if we look across a panel of highly chemo-resistant
pancreatic cancer organoids from Andy Lowy's lab, we
see that we can even deepen the initial responses to KRAS
inhibitor drugs if we preemptively block or
prevent this metabolic escape pathway shown here in a
G12D organoid, where we treat with a KRAS inhibitor
as well as ZBTB11 degrader.
Critically, of course, I showed you that it was not only
important to have that kind of ability to overcome KRAS
inhibitor resistance, but you also need to make sure that you are not
killing neurons which are acutely dependent on oxidative
phosphorylation. So we looked in both cortical and peripheral
neurons using high-content imaging analysis for effects
on the mitochondrial pathway as well as effects on their cellular
health. And I show you just a couple of those here where we're using that
IAX complex one inhibitor that failed in clinical trials as a positive
control. And you can see in red that it has important and
statistically significant effects on neuronal nuclei numbers and neurite
length. Whereas our ZBTB11 degraders and negative
controls shown in blue have no significant effects.
We can show that this is because the key transcripts for
mitochondrial biogenesis and mitoribosome biogenesis are
not exclusively under the transcriptional control of ZBTB11 in a
neuronal context. And so we see no
downregulation of some of those validated
ZBTB11 target genes, and indeed, sometimes we see compensatory
upregulation where these neurons are able to kind of protect or
respond to the loss of ZBTB11 and upregulate those transcripts.
What that means in the context of function is in a sea horse assay, we
see dramatic changes in the neuronal
kind of metabolic index if we use a complex one inhibitor, but we
see no statistically significant changes in the metabolic index of our
neurons in the presence of a ZBTB11 degrader.
Oh, sorry.
And whilst our molecules are not exactly ready for the
clinic yet, what I think is important is because we and others have collected
large amounts of data on the different types of induced proximity modalities that
we use proteome-wide, we can take our relatively small datasets
and build them on top of foundation models of the structure activity
relationships of different types of molecules across the on and
off targets to allow us to more rapidly scaffold hop and improve
both selectivity as well as pharmacokinetic profiling by
changing to preferred scaffolds.
Oh, and so you can see here that we've identified a number of scaffolds, not those
shown on the screen, that can degrade ZBTB11 and have much
improved properties. And so it really is worth, I think, building these
kind of maps of where to go medicinal chemistry wise and then
really exploiting the focus data that you get from looking at your
individual targets to allow you to accelerate your
medicinal chemistry programs, and in this case, really interrogate the function of
an understudied transcription factor that may be interesting for
overcoming resistance to KRAS inhibition in the context of pancreatic
cancer.
And so that brings me to my last but most important slide, which is to acknowledge
all the fantastic people in my lab and all of our many, many
collaborators that have worked with us on these studies.
As well as thanking all of the folks that fund the lab,
thanking Ben for the kind invitation, and thanking all of you for your
attention. I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thanks, Fleur. That was great. Maybe I'll start with the first question.
So this all was possible because you pulled out this
small
20% degradation effect.
And so,
give me a sense of
how much
depth of proteomic profiling you've done on IMID
analogues, those that are canonical and maybe those that are beginning to emerge
now with different cores that even can get beyond the classic G-loop
type substrate profiles. And
it seems like a very powerful approach to pull out
needles in a haystack that you
could then follow up on further. So any thoughts about how...
I guess my question is your thoughts on that type of degradation-first approach
versus phenotype-first approach and their relative
contributions to expanding the repertoire of proteins can be targeted by serve one.
Yeah, I think that that's a great question, and we see it as being incredibly
powerful through many different sessions.
What my lab has focused on more is profiling more broadly on the non-degrader glue
mechanisms. But I think once you have your foot in
the door of something that looks like a scaffold that can recruit a
ligase, recruit an effector protein, recruit a transcription factor,
and you know that that surface is reprogrammable, I think then going
all in on these focused libraries and very focused proteomic approaches can
be incredibly fruitful. I think there's a little bit of luck involved, and
certainly, that's been the case for us.
And so it's also looking at your data sets carefully and knowing when you've been
lucky and when to exploit that, and I think that's something we
hope we do well, and maybe AI can help us with in the future.
Great. Thanks.
Nice presentation. Just curious, does the order of treatment matter?
If you pre-treat with the ZBTB11
degrader, can you prevent KRAS inhibitor resistance?
We haven't done the prevention experiment over the
long term. So whenever you see our ZBTB11
degrader overcoming KRAS inhibitor resistance, those cells are cultured
in KRAS inhibitor in order to maintain the resistance profile.
So we've only tried additive. We've never tried ZBTB11
alone and then remove it and then treat with KRAS inhibitor.
I suspect, given how important KRAS is to the cell,
that
a kind of sequential approach would probably
also develop resistance pretty quickly.
But we do get deeper responses to initial treatment, for example, in
those pancreatic cancer organoids that are multi-chemotherapy resistant but have
never seen KRAS inhibitors. If we treat at the same time,
we can see a higher response. So we think that maybe the prevention
or the kind of sustained efficacy could be interesting.
We're doing those experiments right now to see how long we can prolong the effects.
Thanks.
Okay. Well, I think we're out of time now.
So let me just say thanks again to the speakers.
What a great session. You guys all hit it out of the park.
It was super interesting. We all learned a lot, and thank you again.